what's going on everybody it's a return
of Game of Thrones is upon us so much
went down last season we're gonna break
it down and give you everything you need
to be ready for season four with the
idiots guide to Game of Thrones season
three oh and by the way we're about to
set sail for spoiler ten
oh and if you really need to get caught
up why don't you check out our idiots
guide to seasons 1 & 2 click right here
go ahead click on it I got all day let's
start beyond the wall where we find
bastard John Snow the eternal virgins of
the Nights Watch aka the crows are all
dealing with these albino zombies called
white walkers not only that they're
being set upon by the anything-goes
crazy
dirty wildlings Jon Snow a crow who
happens to look like the crow
intentionally gets captured to spy on
what they're up to
according to his ginger guide Ygritte
you know nothing Jon Snow well he knows
one thing at a bone Ygritte got it on a
hot spring good news they accept him as
one of their own bad news now he's got
to climb over that damn wall again thing
looks harder to scale than the aggro
crag remember that thing I didn't
in spite of some shenanigans on the part
of Garrett's from the British office
they make it over the wall but the jig
is up when Jon Snow won't kill an
innocent man he ditches Ygritte to go
warn his buddies and that she doesn't
take very well I have to go home now
yeah women am i right shooting you with
arrows and stuff now let's go to King's
Landing where the Lannisters reside say
hello to my little friend
get it that's line from Scarface and my
little friend Tyrion Lannister now his
big old scar on his face whether
everybody likes her or not he's got a
regular-size seat at the small councils
big table
over in the ladies quarters new queen to
be Margaery Tyrell is working it so hard
Searcy is not amused if you have a call
me sister again I'll have you strangled
in you seat but King Joffrey is all like
I don't care mom I'm busy having the
most punchable face in King's Landing
that's what intelligent women do with
that toad Joffrey so where does that
leave Sansa Stark
well now she has to marry Tyrion and
that's just weird seriously thinks
hilarious until dad lays down the law
and marries are off to Loras who happens
to be gay fabulous wedding should be
honeymoon so Tyrion marry Sansa gets
waste and mad dogs Joffrey but doesn't
have non-consensual sex with a minor I
won't share your bed
not until you want me to in Game of
Thrones world that makes him an awesome
stand-up dude now we venture cross the
sea to reunite with Daenerys Targaryen
the mother of dragons a hey Khaleesi
where she's almost killed by a little
girl looks like she just finished eating
a blueberry blow pop Daenerys gets saved
by sir Barristan Selmy who is apparently
the biggest badass in Westeros you might
remember he got fired by Joffrey and
threw his sword at that little bastard
he's not a bastard but you know what I
mean
Hallie's Lee needs some ride-or-die
homeys to take back that throne so she
buys 8,000 unsullied slave soldiers she
trades a dragon for this new army then
tells the guy she bought him from I know
you were talking mad crap about me in
another language but Lydia moon you
English new he's ISA so now you're dead
boom she's got the army she's got her
dragons she's got a badass old dude a
guy stuck in the friend zone some real
stud muffin named Dario who murder
anybody for khaleesies killing it time
to free up some more slaves dragon style
emancipation and they worship her for it
now the Khaleesi is not the only badass
chick in the Seven Kingdoms
there's also Arya Stark Arya has a
little bit of bad luck crossing paths in
the Hound what in seven hells are you
doing with his dog [ __ ]
busted The Hound captures our with the
intent of dropping her off at her
uncle's wedding to get some reward money
from her mom and her brother sure that's
gonna work out just fine the hound and
Arya are an odd pair here's another
weird couple Jaime Lannister and big ol
Brienne of Tarth she's escorting Jaime
through the woods towards King's Landing
to exchange him for the stark girls
Jaime and Brienne really need to be in a
buddy cop I hate you but you saved my
life I love you oh no bears and ocean my
hand
oh so Jamie lost his hand he lost a hand
but he did make it back to King's
Landing where he's free to put his hand
and his stump back on his sister's rump
oh and he did meet up with one of Robb
Stark's Bannerman Roose Bolton along the
way where he dropped this little nugget
tell Robb Stark I'm sorry couldn't make
his uncle's wedding the Lannisters send
their regards
that seems innocent enough what you want
more plot lines we've got more plot
lines we've got so many even ones that
no one cares about like bran who's
chasing a three-eyed crow while
travelling with two teenagers Jojen and
Meera Reed who I literally have no idea
who they are I mean the capacity of my
brain to understand character
connections it really maxed out at that
point
I'm not superhuman bran and the mystery
siblings and what's that guy's name
portal learn that bran is a warg able to
control animals with his mind so is
Gareth from the office by the way so
they're chasing the stree eyed crow and
it finds them north of the wall and the
important thing to remember is to
fast-forward through these sections Oh
before I forget
Theon Greyjoy is being tortured by
unknown captors after burning winter
fell to the ground but things are
looking up as he's being seduced by two
babes which is a ruse so they can cut
his dick off what a boner-killer
then his captor Ramsay snow bastard son
of Roose Bolton sends his dad the dick
in a box and his sister Yara is all like
I don't care if we touch my hoo-ha while
we were riding a horse I must avenge my
brothers Wang but enough about those
small fries it's time to get back to the
wannabe kings after the disastrous
Battle of Blackwater the rightful king
Stannis Baratheon is at home licking his
wounds with his sexy adviser slash dark
sorceress Melisandre you know the one
with whom is semen made a demon a stands
old buddy
Davos thinks he's losing
so he tries to kill Melisandre and gets
thrown in the dungeon where he's taught
to read by a little girl on a very
special episode of Game of Thrones and
nope
enough finally we get to our last
contestant on who wants to be king of
this whole Robb Stark he loses half his
army after beheading his right-hand man
Lord Karstark which puts him in the
awkward position of kissing Lord Frey's
ass to get his army back up to snuff
I've come to make my apologies my lord
remember that old coot Robb was supposed
to marry freeze ago daughter but married
his hot nurse wife instead Walder Frey
is a dangerous man to cross to get in
good graces he offers up uncle Edie
mirror to marry afraid go wrong
the Starks arrive for the big wedding
all seems to be going well then they
strike up the band they're having the
reception everyone you love is dead Robb
Stark dead - Lisa stark dead stark
bannermen dead a direwolf
dead Catelyn Stark dead it's the red
wedding ah
ah and when Roose Bolton kills Robb
Stark he drops this little gem the
Lannisters send their regards
that traitorous son of a [ __ ] so where
does that leave us the mother of dragons
is coming the White Walkers are coming
the wildlings are coming Stannis is
brooding Joffrey he still sucks
Tiana's [ __ ] Jon Snow Tyrion and
Arya they may be our only hope everyone
else dead I'm ready for season four what
was your favorite part of season three
let us know in the comments section
below best answer
you're gonna get a screen junkies
t-shirt guys I want to thank you for
watching screen junkies I'm Hal Rudnick
hit me up on Twitter bye bye
it's a different take on the turtles as
we've been hearing up to this point the
original comics are definitely darker
and we're finding like I'm a kid of the
show and looking back on the show
what does it